[Music]
hey rob this is tiffany from iowa i was
just watching parks and rec
and i was just thinking that i think
that that is the best ending of a show
that i've ever seen
i was wondering if you agreed because i
enjoyed all the happy endings
and i think that
all the characters
really progressed with their storyline
and i was wondering how you felt about
that
anyways this is just a millennial loving
rob lowe keep up the good work thanks
bye
oh you millennial tiffany u thank you
for that i appreciate your support and
and all of that i really truly do
um and by the way i hope you're
listening to perks and recollection
um my podcast with alan yang
who um wrote on the series the entire
time where we break down every episode
um it's super fun um yeah
you know what
such a satisfying ending to that show
i agree with you it's
um i think season finales really only go
one or two ways they're either
disastrous
or they're great
um
and then they're the ones that people
feel like
are torn about i love the sopranos
season finale and a lot of people hated
it i loved it but that was great loved
everything about it
um but parks and rec you know it it
fulfilled on the promise of the show
which is
um
feel good
um as you say happy endings to the
characters story lines
um
what's interesting about it
is
it
it was done
right at the beginning of the reboot
phenomenon
like let's bring back will and grace
after a billion years or whatever
and
i think that well i know mike sure did
it in a way
that prevented
any reboot
so that's why it fast forwards
to so many years after the life of the
show
was to kind of
make it tough
that if anybody came in with a check so
big that we all held our nose and
decided to go back and do it again that
we couldn't do it
so that's a little inside baseball on
that
um but yeah thank you um thanks for the
for the watch the listen and um
keep it up thank you so much